ومن رم الله ينضم الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد اذا ابرز ما جرى الاتفاق
عليه بين بلينكن والاسرائيليين وايضا ما
الذي
سيتبادل سطين
اليوم ليس بالضروره ان تكون حسابات
السرايا الامريكيه مطابقه لحسابات البيدر
الاسرائيلي في هذه الحرب وهذه الظروف
العصيبه بلينكن بالامس كانت هناك نقاط
خلافيه بينه وبين الاسرائيليين تعلقت
بالانتقال الى المرحله الث الثالثه والتي
اقتصرت على منطقه شمال قطاع غزه ولم تعد
تعد اسرائيل قواتها الى الحدود المناطق
الحدوديه وانما ابقت على تخوم المناطق
الماهوله التي دمرتها واعلنت ل بلينكن
بانها تواصل عملياتها الحربيه البريه في
جنوبي قطاع غزه هذا احد نقاط الخلاف اما
النقطه الخلافيه الثانيه فتعلقت بكميات
المساعدات الانسانيه التي يتم ادخالها الى
قطاع غزه بلينكن كان يطالب ب 300 شاحنه
يوميا اي مضاعفه اعدادها لتبدا بالدخول
ايضا من منطقه ايرز بيت حانون اسرائيل من
ناحيتها حتى الان لم تاخذ قرارا بهذا
الشان ولم تعطي وعدا قاطعا بهذا الخصوص
والقضيه الثالثه التي كانت خلافيه بينهم
هي تتعلق بامرين الاول وهو مساله ان
بلينكن طالب الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومن
التقاهم وتحديدا رئيسها بضروره ان يتم
تحويل كافه المبالغ التي تحتجزها واقتطعت
من عائدات الضرائب المستحقه على اسرائيل
الى السلطه الفلسطينيه للعلم اسرائيل
وبموجب بروتوكول باريس الاقتصادي الملحق
باتفاق اوسلو مكلفه ومقابله 3% من قيمه
هذه المبالغ التي تجبيها بان تقوم بالاساس
بعمليه جبها على كف فه الواردات الى
الاراضي الفلسطينيه من البضائع سواء من
داخل اسرائيل او من الخارج وتحويلها
للسلطه هذه المره وسوتش وزير الماليه قرر
ان يقتطع منها ما وصفها باموال تدفعها
السلطه الفلسطينيه الى ذوي الارهابيين حسب
تعبيره ولذلك منع تحويلها وهو ما يثقل على
هذه السلطه قدرتها في دفع الرواتب
الامريكيون طالبوا بتحويلها على وجه
السلطه كي لا تنهار هذه السلطه والوضع في
الضفه الغربيه على شفا الانفجار وفق
تقديرات الجهات الامنيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي
حذرت القياده السياسيه من ذلك الموضوع
الاخر هو مساله اعطاء دور للسلطه
الفلسطينيه في اليوم التالي لاداره قطاع
غزه بعد الحرب هذه المواضيع ايضا بلينكن
سيبحثها مع الرئيس الفلسطيني بعد اقل من
ساعتين حيث سيصل الى رام الله وكان امس في
المؤتمر الصحفي قد اشار اليها لكنه قال
على ان السلطه الفلسطينيه يجب ان تجري
اصلاحات في اجهزتها وفي طريقه ادائها كي
تستطيع لعب هذا الدور هذه المساله ليست
مساله بسيطه بنهايه المطاف الاداره
الامريكيه تحاول ان تصيغ جهازا دوليا فيه
دور للسلطه الفلسطينيه من اجل اداره
الشؤون المدنيه في قطاع غزه لكن حتى الان
اسرائيل تواصل حربها واعلنت بانها لن تسمح
بان يكون هناك دور لا للسلطه الفلسطينيه
او كما قال نتنياهو لا لفتح ستان ولا
لحماس ستان لكن ليس بالضروره ان تنتهي
الحرب وفق ما تشتهيه اسرائيل و وتريد
املاه على الجانب الفلسطيني ف خطتها وفق
تصريحات مسؤوليها الكبار نتنياهو وجلن
وجانسو تحديدا نتنياهو هو ان يبقى السلطه
الامنيه بيد اسرائيل في قطاع غزه بمعنى ان
يبقى قطاع غزه تحت الاحتلال سواء بواسطه
الريموت كنترول او مباشره
لمنع اي وجود اي مظاهر سياديه فيه مع
تحويل شانه الاداري المدني فقط لجهات اخرى
اسرائيل لا تريد ان تتحمل المسؤوليه عن
الدمار والقتل الذي الحقته بالقطاع وان لا
تسهم في اعاده اعماره بتاتا وهنا جاء حديث
وزير الخارجيه بلينكن امس وابلغه ايضا
للمسؤولين الاسرائيليين ان من التقاهم من
الزعماء العرب في الدول المفتاح كما سماها
وتركيا هو انهم مستعدون للاسهام ويريدون
ولكن يريدون مظله سياسيه على اساس ان يكون
هناك عمليه سياسيه تنتهي بان بحل هذا
الصراع باقامه دوله فلسطينيه الى جانب
اسرائيل وايضا انهم يريد يريدون ان لا
يتسع رقعه الحرب في المنطقه هذه الامور
نقلها الى الجانب الاسرائيلي وتحدث مع
الجانب الاسرائيلي عن وجود رغبه بفتح
عمليه التطبيع من جديد بعد انتهاء هذه
الحرب وهذه امور سينقلها ايضا للجانب
الفلسطيني الرئيس الفلسطيني الذي سيستقبل
بلينكن بعد نحو ساعتين او اقل سيغادر بعد
ذلك للمشاركه في قمه اردنيه مصريه
فلسطينيه في العقبه لبحث نفس هذه المواضيع
لان ان مساله ما هو دور السلطه قدره
السلطه اصلا على لعب دور هي محل شك حتى
الان سواء بسبب ضعفها وسبب ترهل اجهزتها
او بسبب ان اسرائيل ايضا لا تريد ان
تعطيها اي دور ولا ترى فيها شريكا في هذه
المعادله لكن الامريكيين من ناحيتهم يسعون
لاعطائها دور ولو محدود في اطار جهاز دولي
سواء كان عربي ام دوليا بشكل عام موضوع
الذي تحدث عنه بلينكن بخصوص الامم المتحده
هو قال انه تفاهم مع الاسرائيليين على ان
الامم المتحده تقيم جهازا ل لمتابعه الوضع
في غزه وتحديد ما اذا هناك مجال لبدء عوده
الغزيين الى شمالي القطاع بعد ان تنضج
الظروف نعم